from the daily wires is on tuesday the
father of a biological girl who believes
she's a boy
turned himself into a canadian court and
was subsequently taken to jail
after the attorney general of british
columbia issued an arrest warrant
for contempt after the father had
insisted on referring to his daughter as
his daughter
and used the pronoun she and her god
forbid
robert hoogland from surrey british
columbia
has a 14 year old daughter in february
2019 the supreme court
of british columbia ordered that the
girl received testosterone injections
without obtaining parents like i said
14 years old
this is four years before this this
child is considered an adult
able to make adult decisions
14 certainly under the age of consent
anywhere in the western world as far as
i know
can't consent at 14 by the law you can't
consent to like anything
without without your parent involved
except this
except um injecting foreign chemicals
into your body
to try to change your body
in in profound and permanent ways
the the long-lasting permanent side
effects of which
we don't even fully know yet
um so it says canada ordered that the
girl received testosterone injections
without obtaining parental consent
the federalist notes that the court also
declared that if either of her parents
referred to her using female pronouns or
addressed her by her birth name
they would be considered guilty of
family violence
canada has lost its mind completely
well the entire western world has but
canada is a little bit there's a few
train cars up ahead of us on the crazy
train
when she was in seventh grade the girls
uh school urged the girl to see
psychologist dr wallace wong
who recommended the girl should begin
taking cross-sex hormones at 13.
hugeland cited his daughter's alleged
history of mental health issues and
refused to give permission
doctors at bc children's hospital
decided that the girl should receive
testosterone injections
and um and now fast forward a little bit
legally he's not even allowed to refer
to his his own daughter as a daughter as
a girl he's arrested for that
and if you're living south of the
canadian border you live in america and
you think
they're crazy up there that's never
going to happen here oh it'll happen
here that this this is happening here
this will happen they've already laid
the groundwork for it
lay the groundwork first through the
rejection of
biological science the rejection of
objective more
uh reality and morality
and then by saying that it's you know
it's it's hateful
to use biologically correct pronouns
when referring to someone
it's an act of hate
well if that's the case then it's all
it's only so long before they say well
there need to be laws in place to
protect
you know gender confused people from
hearing the correct biological pronouns
and this this again shows why it is so
important for us to
to not go along with this
it is not a small issue the gender stuff
in general
as you know i believe and have always
said not at all a small issue this is a
central issue in the culture
but the pronoun piece of that
it's very very important that is a hill
worth dying on
and you don't even have to die because
i've been fighting on that hill for a
long time and i'm still
kicking but that's a hill worth
defending
once you go along with that it's over
and there are more and more again
more and more people on the right who
who even
you know suppose right-wing media
publications you see this more and more
that start using
the preferred pronouns in their articles
and that sort of thing
this this is a matter of reality i'm not
going to go along
with a lie i won't do it i can't
morally i can't
that's the stance we all have to take
it's not you're not trying to hurt
anyone's feelings
you're not being aggressive about it no
something is being demanded of you
you're not doing this
i'm not doing it i didn't choose to have
this discussion
i'm going about my life going about my
day
using correct normal language
and now i'm being told that i have to
use language
that does not signify what i'm actually
trying to convey
[Music]
so something is being asked of me that
is unreasonable
all i'm doing is saying no i can't go
along with that unreasonable demand
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content